das lokal herzlich willkommen hier heute
meine damen und herren zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal in dem wir uns
gemeinsam amazon fels anschauen werden
das hier ist ein teppich den eine person
auf amazon bestellen wollte ich hey das
ist ja ein richtig schöner teppich der
wird super meine wohnung passen da freue
ich mich ja schon mega wenn der
geliefert wird dann wird er allerdings
geliefert und ist nur so groß der
teppich passte halt nicht mehr über
einen kleinen kaffeefleck also das
nächste mal würde ich mir die
abmessungen anschauen machen wir weiter
für diesen pilz und zwar einen
kissenbezug von einem dinosaurier da
denkt man sich als elternteil halt hey
das ist ein super geschenk für mein kind
das wird sich mega freuen sondern
dinosaurier kiss und zu haben
was dann allerdings angekommen ist ist
das hier bleiben wir allerdings
schwierig bei amazon fels und ja das ist
auch das thema des heutigen videos lukas
das hier ist ein workout t shirt für
herren und es betont natürlich die
muskeln und ist dementsprechend auch ein
bisschen enger
das ist allerdings so eng und
gleichzeitig so lang ist hätte ich diese
bis glaube ich nicht gedacht
beim nächsten amazon fell wurde nicht
wirklich dieses produkt bestellt und
sich dann darüber gewundert hey das ist
ja eine ganz andere größe oder sieht ja
ganz anders aus
das allgemeine produkt ist einfach schon
kompletter vereine doppelpack warnweste
für hühner in gelb also das nächste mal
spazieren gehen will dann bestelle ich
bin deine doppelpack warnweste das
nächste produkt stand allerdings wieder
aus der kategorie her ich habe mir etwas
bestellt aber es ist eine komplett
andere größer als angegeben
und zwar sollte das hier ein neuer tv
schrank sein
ich würde sagen nein war direkt bei den
komischen größen das hier ist ein
dunkelbrauner sessel von einem
unternehmen namens kin fein auf den usa
er kostet 86 dollar sieht relativ cool
aus angekommen ist allerdings diese
größer
ja dass die definitiv gemütlich aus der
nächste amazon feldes mehr oder weniger
genau so wie der dinosaurier kissenbezug
fällt den ich euch zu beginn gezeigt
habe und zwar geht es diesmal um diese
tafel man denkt halt weil da steht bevor
und eine schwarze tasche und dann after
und eine blaue tasse mit merry christmas
logo das die taste dementsprechend halt
irgendwie die oberfläche oder die farbe
verändert angekommen ist die tasse
allerdings so allerdings direkt zum
nächsten aber zum fell und zwar geht es
hierbei um ein paket das eine tochter
für ihre mutter bestellt hat allerdings
nicht direkt für ihre mutter sondern für
eine überraschungsparty die für die
mutter veranstaltet werden sollte und
zwar waren dort drin party supplies also
zubehör für die party et cetera von
daher dürfte allerdings die mutter
nichts davon mitkriegen da die tochter
noch bei ihrer mutter wohnte tochter hat
sich da auf jeden fall gedacht hey ich
schreib einfach in die die livery
instructions dass das ganze eine
überraschung ist für meine mutter und
ist dementsprechend nicht nach party
zubehör aussehen soll
amazon hat die
amazon hat einfach direkt auslassen
brandstätter aufgeschrieben wird euch
worten die mutter kommt nach hause und
findet eine box von wegenetzes preis
body for my mother priester und max
lykov usa gut machen wir weiter mit
komischen größen geliefert wurden
das hier ja ich glaube so viel suppe
kann kein mensch essen und auch das hier
sollte eigentlich eine brot brötchen mit
messer sein ist letztendlich aber nicht
größer als nagelknipser und auch beim
nächsten haben wir einen interessanten
größenunterschied und zwar geht es um
dieses hunde gitter angekommen ist
allerdings diese größe so lange wie die
beine von dem hund beim nächsten mal zum
fällen geht es nicht um einen großen
unterschied sondern es geht um einen
material unterschied
es handelt sich hierbei um diese jesus
angekommen sind allerdings diese
haushalt offen
zu guter letzt kommt mir jetzt
allerdings noch zu drei amazon fällt
sich euch rausgesucht habe wo ich mir
einfach denke hey wer bestellt so was
und viel mehr warum gibt es so etwas
überhaupt zu bestellen das tier
beispielsweise ist eine handy hülle mit
dem titel wie teenage girl bedrooms
pregnancy testing kit cell phone cover
case also eine hülle auf der eine frau
ist die gerade einen
schwangerschaftstest anschaut und sieht
dass sie schwanger ist
die sein würde ich direkt bestellen oder
auch hier beispielsweise eine handy
hülle auf der einfach eine heroinspritze
zu sehen ist würde ich auch direkt
meinem kind bestellen aber zu guter
letzt noch die jugend ist der handy
hören die ich euch heute zeigen werde
und zwar geht es um diese hier
das ist einfach eine handy hülle auf der
sich eine frau botox in die lippen
spritzen lässt
ja ich würde
stück bestellen an der stelle ich das
heutige video ist auch beenden dann
lieben freunde wenn euch diese episode
amazon fans gefallen hat dann die seile
daumen hoch unter dem video hier das
schaffen wir 50.000 likes also das wären
mega krass wenn ihr das schaffen würde
würde ich mir auf jeden fall denken hey
vielleicht haben die leute bock auf dem
zweiten teil schreibt mir auf jeden fall
werden in die kommentare bei einem
zweiten teil hiervon sehen wollte
abonniert main kanal falls das dann
nicht verpassen wollte
[Musik]